quando c'è questa musica di sottofondo
posso non pensare tipo alle p cita
totale basta solo guardare il bambino
che faccia ci siamo su piazza il glory
ragazzi se non ve lo ricordate è meglio
giocare crea giocare siccome ho visto
che sono uscite un miliardo di facce di
comunità e ho fatto queste duro è tipo
ecco che glielo se riesco a fare
qualcosa di decente stavolta ti svegli
in un mondo che non è il mondo reale
ok vai proviamoci non so cosa pensare di
questo la puoi fare con johnny jack and
jill picchiavano sono questi due cose
uno sturalavandini qua jack and jill a
nella personalizzazione del personaggio
bellissimo quindi posso portare una
bambina a caso completamente nel
carrellino dietro va bene questo gioco è
seriamente family friendly soprattutto
per quello che sta per succedere allora
la bambina non vale sempre invece poi no
tutto bene zia credo non si sia fatto
niente di male a posto va bene io vorrei
semplicemente arrivare se riesco al
traguardo ho avuto l'effetto sonoro del
che ha fatto la bambina quando s'è
schiantata va bene ripartiamo quasi come
è come si sa ma c'è il game pad
ditelo subito allora come si fa col game
pad abbiamo così se riesco a far
qualcosa di decente a perfetto ho già
più controllo la bambina avevo già persa
quindi perfetto game pad e la cosa
giusta porto schifo
no no no ahia non me ne frega ma quale
si mise incastrato il carrello e va bene
va bene family friendly tantissimo
quanto mi monetizzerà questo video da 1
a devo pagare io per farvelo vedere
ragazzi a rifiutare una cosa che non
c'entra niente
menu meno principale segnare un errore
leaderboard cambiamento pista
ricominciare respon curriculum vitae e
non ho mai capito come si dice sta però
per questa strada minchia c'entra va
bene non importa alla riusciva ad
arrivare maledizione a quel punto o amen
bene l'hai presa giustissima però almeno
teoria c'è poi in sono contenti sono
andare dritto zio dritto zio bravo così
bravo bravo la bambina si è salvata io
no
madonna che l'epa non è che sia proprio
il posto ideale per giocare a dodge ball
questo comunque va beh
[Musica]
grazie vai vai vai bimba vai vai cosa
sta succedendo ipad a la donna come dove
aiuto sono ancora in gioco
com'è possibile dovrei solo riuscirebbe
a sei tranquillo bambino e tutto va bene
lasciamo perdere esponiamo perfetto ho
perso la bambina chissenefrega vai
veloce vado vado e vabbé dribbling ok
comunque sarà la mappa se non ricordo
male l'ha più fatta con questi va bene
giustamente se venissi da me
bravo buono traguardo
allora sono stato bravo mi è piaciuto
cambiamento pista allora per rivedere
the circus of the questo mi sento più
carico degli altri hanno aggiunto
bottoni personaggi c'è anche junior
completa 20 tracce per sbloccarlo ok zoe
ciao è vedere come 6 con la moto
secondo me te la cavi bene questo è il
mestiere che fa per te e benissimo
benissimo zoe bravissima così no
braccialetto quello a oggi ha preso c'è
poi quindi questo lo posso prendere con
tranquillità dopo il successo ma potete
essere così stupidi da mettere il
circuito qui sotto buono
no ok porchia vacca
mi sa che quali sono fatto malissimo ma
vabbè e proviamo ora lenti rega mamma mi
dai non l'aveva colpita non sono appesa
niente eccolo perfetto non so come ho
fatto che va bene l'oro va bene va bene
che male che male tutto senza mai morire
trai morire fenomeno fenomeno ci avevo
creduto tantissimo forse un po troppo
porto schifo o che centro vincitori mai
smettere e anch'io lo pensavo stamattina
ok allora questo è proprio i campioni di
come rischiano se giocasse in glory
famiglie de son curioso jack o sbloccato
la cacca sono un campione sono un
campione let's go baby perfetto buono
o era difficile quanto pare si sono solo
vivo non mi ha tagliato perché non era
la parte della moda quindi per tornare
su sorella tiramisù sono qua guardami mi
vedi non alzare la testa che se non vuoi
tagliarti i capelli potrebbe essere un
problema allora edizione
no ma allora io posso mai avere
che problemi hai ho perso mia ski se ne
frega dov'è andato a finire perché vado
a vedere e lì a destra e che senza la
sorella sono bravissimi
hai visto sono svenuto dal nulla proprio
ok ok va bene dovevo andare lì sopra
prove rifacciamo ho mancato il bersaglio
grosso ancora vivo perchè fenomeno con
una mano sola
dai bambina lurida ok extra stai lì
brava gioca come barbie stai lì ferma
faccio io mi servirebbe una mano nel
vero senso della parola
questo è successo la mia pc ok sono
arrivati fin quando mandar giù
bene molto bene e la un fenomeno adesso
qui non riusciva a fare il giro non
posso andare
ok però sono caduto allora ce l'abbiamo
fatta finalmente farsa parte maledetta
quindi piano piano piano piano piano
piano piano no no no no no per cortesia
ci ho messo due ore mamma mia che però
guardano da ora ci credo ce l'ha quasi
l'ho preso perché me la meritavo nella
verità vera bellissimo ho preso senza
maiorca vacca attenzione e piano piano
piano piano piano piano piano piano sto
bene incredibile
vai vai la rai senza la sorella vai può
in teoria non dovrebbe arrivare la palla
è arrivata lo stesso piano piano seguì
me segui me c'è un tipo che mi spara la
finestra
seguimi ok
tutto bene hai visto
hai visto che ha dato tutto bene limite
se non sono fratello migliore del mondo
noi ragazzi facciamo l'ultima di oggi
visto che questa raramente [ __ ] vorrei
provare a vedere se riusciamo a farne un
altro tipo balconi terror pedro chi è
pietro cosa diavolo sta cosa vedo
bravissimo pedro
mamma mia vita prova a lanciare solo
pedro aspetto che ci riprova fi pedro
fai vedere chi sei
bene chissà che questo non è un bel
livello per pedro o chi c'era questa mi
sembra simpatica pronto a partire
dove però devo andare di qua piano
sorella seguimi sorella seguimi sorella
seguì non far pagare bene orca vacca lo
devo spiegare io a mamma questo va bene
devo passare in mezzo alle basse da
baseball e andata benissimo forza paesi
o ok bravi non ci credo
una volta che hai fatto una cosa che
volevo andasse esattamente così cosa è
successo
benissimo benissimo siamo forse in
dirittura d'arrivo regala forse qua mia
sorella potrebbe effettivamente servire
per fare il contro bilancio non è vero
non serva una sega dai matrix foto vatri
un fenomeno come ho fatto a fare sta
parte bellissima niente sono schiantare
è stato belli come ho fatto
geniale ne sarebbe andata buono perfetto
se non ci arriva adesso con una gamba
pedalando non ci arrivo più di sbagliare
qua bravissime ma tu sì che sempre
adesso dobbiamo solo andare dritti
secondo me sta bene perfetto che se
quella roba lì è una banana
non lo sapremo mai perché sono morto
malissimo quasi in dirittura d'arrivo
miss a questo è l'ultimo pezzo è stato
andata meglio se riuscissi a saltare
sopra le perfette i pomodori mi si è
impantanata alla bici rai non sbagliare
ti ammazzo bravissimo bravissimo
bravissima così ti voglio sempre così ti
voglio carico carico e pronto a pedalare
che brutta cosa vedo sono a proferire
malissimo che faccio lo faccio questa
cosa molto bella e fuck the system forte
sistema ima pro gamer finale poi vedere
cosa avete inventato per il finale
incastra ma dove avete prese st bici è
preso i pezzi di ricambio dalla
discarica ma non dura niente ok ok ok ok
ok ok ok buono gran finale devo passare
l'elica buona fortuna va bene vabbè ma
non ci arriverò mai allora prendiamo
tantissima rincorsa tipo voglio provare
arrivare al massimo della mia velocità
che comunque fa veramente pena quindi
non è che proviamo allora con l'avola
spacca ultimo tentativo vai o vinco
perdo gli oli biol issimo
sono fantastico bello sapevo già grazie
signori ci ha messo sei ore per fa sta
roba
spero che video vi sia piaciuto è un
gioco sempre bello da giocare questo mi
piace tantissimo però questi ragazzi vi
è piaciuto accertamento mi piace anche
la descrizione sono state e non ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo
dai ragazzi
[Musica]